it's late into the evening in Emir a
town in Western Iran
and a confrontation between
anti-government protesters and Iranian
police is about to turn nasty
people hide and run down the narrow
Alleyways to escape the gunshots of the
feared basiji militia
a 16 year old boy is hit
he's taken to hospital the doctors try
to save him but Abdullah
dies of his wounds
another casualty of the protests across
Iran
it's the following morning a crowd has
gathered at the town's mosque
abdullah's body is carried to be buried
along with a second man who died the
previous night
hundreds turn up to the cemetery to
grieve with the families
[Music]
[Music]
was in a mere town when this happened
a great risk he smuggled this video
footage out of Iran
if he'd been caught at the border his
life would have been in danger
even here just inside a rock he's not
safe
he tells us what happened on the
following night
um
foreign
[Music]
foreign
that night some of Muhammad's friends
were arrested and tortured they were
beaten he says one of them had their
finger and toenails pulled out
were you surprised by
the violence
that the security forces used or or was
this what you were expecting
um
foreign
by now after two days of violent
Crackdown in ermia three were dead and
many wounded
in Revenge protesters stormed the basiji
police station taking out furniture and
burning it in the streets
these images are a 48-hour snapshot of
just one town during more than 40 days
of ongoing Nationwide protests
the Iranian Security Forces don't want
the outside world to see this footage
The Bravery of Muhammad Ahmadi though
has made sure they have
Alistair Buckle Sky News in Northern
Iraq